well the party may be over for party boy
boris johnson a total of 28 conservative
back benches i've now publicly demanded
his removal and if that number reaches
54 and others may have done so
anonymously he'll face a career defining
no confidence vote
joining me now to talk to you very
similar to kate mckenzie kate
this is getting serious for boris
johnson isn't it because also tonight
lord guyt has revealed serious concerns
about boris johnson's adherence to the
ministerial code in relation to the
fixed penalty notices that he got and
you're getting people like you know
andrea led some seasoned you know pro
boris politicians now coming out against
him too
i'm feeling the heat from here and it's
getting a bit ferocious
yeah look i think andrea ledson was a
real moment for those in number 10 today
because they believe that so far it's
the usual suspects the people who never
really liked boris johnson pretty much
always wanted to see the back door see
him leave downing street and then today
that moment when a brexiteer supposedly
one of his own has said not quite that
he needs to leave but that his behavior
isn't good enough and i think lord guy's
report might be the moment for some more
over the weekend because lord guy
essentially saying unless the prime
minister sticks to his own code of
conduct well things could get really
difficult he even hinted in his pretty
long report today piers that he may have
considered resigning if the prime
minister hadn't listened to his advice
and he's pretty frustrated it has to be
said so it looks like more trouble for
boris johnson though the mood at number
10 i have to say is defiant they've come
out swinging essentially they believe he
could win this vote and they would like
to bring it on right and just to clarify
if he does win the vote he buys himself
at least another year isn't it before
they can try again is that right
yeah that's right 54 letters into graeme
brady and then a vote triggered within a
matter of hours most likely boris
johnson needs 180 plus one mps in order
to get past that but then he's safe for
a year under 1922 rules now in number 10
there is a feeling that that could mean
the best time for that vote may well be
next week because it comes before a
by-election it comes before the
privileges committee report essentially
before any more bumps in the road that
might cause him some trouble and if he
wins it he is then safe a note of
caution though in january this year it
was suggested they could try and change
the rules so that a vote could be held
every six months it was rejected at the
time but it could come back again if
there are those in the 22 who feel it
really is time up for boris johnson and
what's extraordinary is in the last few
minutes we've now heard that the durham
police have now sent formal
questionnaires to the leader of the
labour party sakia stammer and his
deputy angela raynor and they only do
that if they suspect a covered rule was
actually broken and both of them have
said if they do actually get fined by
the police they will resign so we could
have a situation in the next few weeks
where we lose everybody at the top of
both parties
could be a complete clear out in which
case what does it leave the liberal
democrats who could come riding over the
hill to try and form some kind of
government of course not likely to
happen but in all seriousness it does
show you just how frustrated people are
with the state of politics at the moment
here in the uk in westminster that the
most senior people in the conservative
party have faced fines and now the most
senior people in the labour party are
facing questions over their own conduct
it's not a good place to be it's not
kate mccann thank you very much indeed
well joining me now is formerly the
scottish conservative party baroness
ruth davis and ruth everson thank you so
much for joining me it's it's an
extraordinary situation isn't it in
british politics where you have the
current prime minister boris johnson
who's coming under siege now from his
own party from his own ethics standards
uh
boss uh from all sides it seems and at
the same time the leader of the
opposition kirsten and his number two
are also subject to a police
investigation for also breaking lock
down rules
i think this is appears basically
because we were told as a country by
people at the top that this was serious
that these rules were serious that
sticking to these rules was serious that
it was a matter of life and death and
that this was a time of
national uh crisis and as such there was
a collective endeavor to stick to the
spirit of the rules to stick to the
letter of the rules and that's what
would see us through as a country and i
think people uh certainly a large
proportion of people are rightly angry
when they see
those that set those restrictions up
whether it was the prime minister who
stood at elector and told them they had
to stay at home or was the leader of the
opposition who voted it through uh
looking as if it was one rule for
everybody else but but those rules that
they set for us didn't apply to them and
and that's why
people who weren't able to hold the hand
of a loved one as they died weren't able
to go to a funeral weren't able to visit
an isolated new mother won't forget
what they gave up and what they
sacrificed because they thought they
were doing the right thing and because
they were told that's what they had to
do
i mean there are still conservative
politicians who stand by boris johnson
i'm about to talk to peter bone after i
talk to you he's a long-standing
conservative mp
you know for many years um what's your
message to them i mean do you believe
that the
integrity not just of the prime minister
and the government but at the
conservative party is now at stake here
well actually i care more about what
this is doing to the country necessarily
than the party although of course it's
deeply damaging to the party um but
for me
particularly at a time of national
crisis
you need the leader in the land the
first among equals
to be judged to a higher standard not a
lower one he needs to set an example he
needs to have moral authority and that's
nothing to do with whoever holds the
post of prime minister that's to do with
the office of prime minister itself and
if people look at an office be
introduced in this way if they look at
people who are at the very top going
well actually we don't have to stick by
the rules then that does filter down to
people and they go well well why should
i stick by the rules either right and i
do think that it is damaging uh to the
country and to the institution i'm a
conservative because i support the
institutions of this country and to see
them introduced like this you know i i
find it
deeply deep i'm deeply uneasy about it
do you think boris johnson will survive
this
i think this is a really interesting
week because uh the parliament's off for
a week it means everybody's back in
their constituencies they're doing loads
of things with constituents around the
jubilee they're having a lot of people
come up and speak to them they're
getting a sense of the depth and the
breadth of feeling in a way they might
not do when they're in
westminster you know five six days four
five six days a week so i think that the
trickle that you're seeing in the last
couple of days is part of that and we
may see a few more many people ruth
davidson think that if there is a
vacancy
to be leader of the conservative party
uh you
ought to be putting your name forward
you were very popular when you were up
there in scotland many people wished
he'd come down here and being perhaps
prime minister when boris johnson took
the job are you interested if there is a
vacancy
no i'm not interested i value my mental
health and my family life too much i've
got a young son and i'm not interested
in the job and nor am i qualified to
hold it i'm not an mp so um even if i
were which i'm not i couldn't put myself
forward but what i do want to see is i
want to see somebody in the role who
understands what the expectations are of
the job uh and
what it is that they have to do to
uphold the standards of public life that
we need to expect from our leaders and
that we need to demand from our leaders
well i mean i completely agree i mean i
just find it extraordinary to have a
prime minister who actually got a fixed
penalty notice from the police for
breaking one of his own laws i mean i
just don't know how any prime minister
in history that i can remember
could or should have survived that
moment
i mean i you know i respect my
colleagues they've been put in a very
difficult position colleagues on the
green benches in westminster but but
what i don't understand is how they can
look at the damage that is being done
and if you asked any of them away from
this you know do you think it's
acceptable for a prime minister to break
a law that he says they would say no and
if you ask them do you think it's
acceptable for a prime minister uh to
you know be charged by the police uh and
just carry on as if nothing had happened
or not refer himself to the ministerial
court or do you you know is it
acceptable for a prime minister to stand
up in parliament and say he's appalled
by something that he didn't know
anything about and it turns out that he
not only knew about it he participated
in it i mean do you think any of these
things are acceptable they would all say
no do you think i don't understand is
why they're currently sitting on their
hands do you think he's an honest man
boris
johnson don't know i've got no window to
see into another man's soul um but i
think that when he stood up in
parliament uh after allegra stratton the
only person to have resigned over this
let's not forget and and she resigned
not because she attended anything but
because she was caught on camera being
unable to answer a question about it
because she knew it was wrong uh
standing up saying he was appalled and
the people that he knew nothing about
had done things that were wrong and he
was going to get to the bottom of it
when he stood up and said that
he knew
that he was there and i think that that
act in parliament was a dishonest act
i could not agree more uh baroness
davidson thank you very much please come
back and be an mp soon
a chance you know you you know you want
to i'll take that man i'll take that
money in a bit i'd love to talk to you
thank you very much
thank you peers
well i'm joined now by conservative mp
for wellingborough
you are almost a unique creature right
now you're a conservative mp
hitting the airwaves quite regularly
staunchly defending boris johnson
why
well i think most of my conservative
colleagues support the prime minister
100 there's only a minority that don't
and they've never supported the prime
minister
do you think boris johnson's an honest
man
absolutely
i mean he was fired as a journalist from
the times for lying he was fired from a
position under michael howe for lying
about an extra marital affair people
think he's lied about party gate the
track record of honesty is not good
well i think
i think you're slightly wrong on what
you call partygate a metropolitan police
investigation which cost half a million
pounds went over many weeks and 12 to 12
detectives were on the case
and the only he wasn't found guilty of
partying he had one fixed penalty notice
when he went into
the cabinet office i believe and he was
presented with a cake which he didn't
know anything about in advance
and surprisingly the chancellor also got
a fixed penalty energy when he thought
he was going in there for a meeting as
well that's not partying um and so well
i'm not sure okay hang on why you
suggested lied well yeah but that's your
that's your
your impression is it's not partying but
actually that's exactly what the police
deduced it was they investigated all of
this and they issued him with a fixed
penalty notice for literally
breaking lockdown rules by having an
illegal gathering that he was at an
illegal gathering that's why he got a
police fine i mean the implication of
what you're saying is the police were
wrong to find him is that what you're
saying
no i'm saying that that wasn't what you
and i would call the party you're right
to say that he attended an event which
she didn't know was about to happen he
was there for nine minutes
and they the police decided to find him
from that but you're not going to
suggest to me that that was in any way
what most people would call the parties
well we also know that we also know that
no it was reported at the time as well
and nobody complained about it at the
time but we also yeah but the the point
about all this surely is that it's the
scale of the parting the illegal parting
that was going on at downing street the
fact that over 80 people working there
got police fines for breaking the laws
that were made by the people at downing
street and that they were doing the
partying when they were ordering the
public not even to go and see
dying relatives in hospital it's the
totality of what has gone here in boris
johnson's home which is what it is and
the idea frankly that not only was he
personally fined but that he knew
nothing about any of these parties when
they were on the lash until 4 a.m the
night before prince phillips funeral for
example in number 10. i just don't
believe it i just i think that's a
dishonest response by the prime minister
well i think you're wrong you will of
course know that prime minister was not
in downing street when the party you
referred to
occurred
and you will also know that 10 downing
street is a huge office block going over
five floors
and most the vast majority of people who
are working in downing street at the
time
behaved properly and and
unabided by the
rules very large number of hangovers
a large number of them according to the
report we all read last week they were
vomiting they were fighting allegedly
fornicating breaking swings belonging to
the prime minister's son it was just
completely lawless environment in there
and boris johnson may not have been
physically there for every one of them
but it's his home he's the boss these
people all work under him and there's
been no accountability by the prime
minister for the fact that all this was
going on and he himself got fined as
well and i just i just ask you if this
had been a labor prime minister
would you have had the same opinion or
would you have taken the view that no
serving prime minister should ever
survive getting fined by the police for
breaking their own rules in a pandemic
i i certainly would have taken the same
view of being a labour prime minister
and i i take the view that kia stammer
and his deputy
shouldn't resign if they get a fixed
penalty notice because i don't think
they thought that they were breaking the
rules at the time either
and the fact that there are thousands of
people that work in downing street i
mean
talk tv
you're you're almost the head of it in
some many ways you're not the head of
talk to you you are their chief prisoner
i'm not well you're the you're the star
but you don't you you don't run
you don't run the office you don't know
you wouldn't and i wouldn't expect you
to run the office and i wouldn't expect
the prime minister to run in the office
i mean part of the time these so-called
parties occurred boris was in hospital
fighting for his life because of all the
efforts he'd put in
during the covet pandemic so i i think
we have to be careful what we're saying
when we're suggesting that these parties
occurred in his home well that's not
really the situation when we know that
it's a five-story office block before
behind that uh well i've been in
downtown street many times and it is a
home and you do know what's going on and
frankly if you don't know as prime
minister that 80 odd of your staff
are breaking your lock down rules on a
regular basis sometimes with large
karaoke parties involving large amounts
of alcohol if you don't know that's all
going on then it's a failure of
leadership isn't it as well
well i disagree
it's a failure certain people who are
running the downing street operation
that's correct but the metropolitan
police didn't find that the prime
minister had been partying at all these
events you're referring to now the
changes have all well the changes
occurred actually
before the sue grey report came out
because there was an interim report and
the prime minister acted on it and those
people have gone and there's a
completely new system in downing street
to make sure this would wouldn't happen
again so i think the prime minister's
done what sue grey wants he's apologized
and i think most people in the country
uh want him to get on with the job i was
stopped by a constituent today when i
was walking into wellingborough and he
said look i was a labor man but i
switched to conservatives because of
boris he got us through brexit he got us
through covid for goodness sake leave
him alone and let him get on with
running the country and i think that's
what most people in the country think
yeah you could take your view that
brexit was bad for the country and you
could take your view that his early
handling the pandemic was a complete
disaster
so it depends who you talk to but peter
bone i appreciate you coming on piers
morgan unscented it's good to see thank
you